[Zene]
képzeld el hogy van egy láthatatlan
bankszámlát amelyet minden egyes
emberrel közösen vezetsz a családoddal a
munkatársaiddal a barátaiddal minden
egyes őszinte gesztus betartott ígéret
és tiszteletteljes kommunikáció egy
betét ezen a számlán de minden egyes
megtett ígéret hazugság vagy
tiszteletlenség egy kivétel amely
csökkenti az egyenleget
[Zene]
az első két epizódban két természeti
alaptörvényt vettünk amelyek nem csak az
emberekre igazak hanem valamiért
áthatják az univerzumunkat is a
növekedés alapelvéről beszéltünk és a
paretto elvről ebben az epizódban
viszont egy olyan alapelvet hoztam
számotokra ami csak az emberekre
jellemző a bizalom alapelvét
a bizalom a társadalom kötőszövete egy
láthatatlan erő ami összeköt és megtart
egy közösséget egy családot vagy egy
munkaközösséget ha a bizalom alacsony
egy ilyen közösségben akkor minden
kaotikussá kiszámíthatatlanná válik az
embereknek rejtett szándékaik lesznek
alacsony hatásokkal fognak működni és
nem vállalnak rizikót inkább egymásra
mutogatnak ha baj van ezzel szemben ha a
bizalom magas akkor letisztulnak a
kapcsolatok az emberek mernek
sérülékennyé válni egymás előtt és
emiatt rizikót vállalni a problémák
szinte maguktól oldódnak meg és a
szervezet hatékonysága merőben növekszik
mivel a bizalom láthatatlan ezért sokan
azt gondolják hogy nincs is rá szükség
mert helyettesíteni tudja ezt például
egy szerződés stevenhen cavy fia a
bizalom sebessége című könyvben gyakran
mondogatta hogy ahol a bizalom magas ott
minden gyorsabb és minden olcsóbb míg
ahol a bizalom alacsony ott minden
lassabb és drágább nekem sokat segített
kavi példája hogy jobban megértsem a
bizalom fontosságát ha úgy gondolok a
bizalmatlanságra mint egy rejtett adóra
képzeljük el hogy a bruttó fizetésünkből
nem csak jövedelemadót
társadalombiztosítási járulékot
egészségügyi biztosítást kell fizetnünk
hanem egy rejtett bizalmatlansági adót
is amely akár 20% is lehet ha elég nagy
a bizalmatlanság egy szervezetben akkor
akár teljesen felemésztheti a
potenciális profitot ha így gondolunk a
bizalmatlanság árára a akkor hirtelen
nagyon értékessé válik a bizalom
bizonyos szempontból egy nemzetben
meglevő bizalom a legnagyobb erőforrás
az adott társadalomnak fontosabb mint a
természeti erőforrásai sok olyan ország
van amelyik bővelkedik például kőolajban
mint nigéria vagy venezuela mégis az
átlagos életszínvonal alacsony a belső
korrupció miatt és vannak olyan országok
mint például japán vagy szingapúr
amelyeknek alig van természeti
erőforrásuk mégis a társadalomban
meglevő magas bizalmi szint belső
fegyelem jó minőségű oktatás és a
biztonság miatt kiemelkedően magas
életszínvonalt tudnak elérni mi emberek
közösségi lények vagyunk és a közösséget
a bizalom köti össze annyira mélyen
belénk van kódolva hogy biológiai
szempontból is így fejlődött az ember az
ember az egyetlen emlős akinek
hangsúlyos a szemeefehérje és ez nem
véletlen a szemfehérje azért alakult ki
hogy lássuk a másik ember merre néz mit
figyel mit tart fontosnak ha látjuk
merre néz azt is jobban megértjük mi r a
fejében ez annyira érzékenyen fejlődött
ki bennünk hogy ha valaki például 10 m
távolságból néz felénk meg tudjuk
mondani hogy pontosan ránk néz vagy
mellettünk 10 cm-rel elnéz ha tudom hogy
a másik nem rejteget semmit hogy nyíltan
és egyenesen rám néz akkor könnyebben
megbízom benne a ragadozók szeme
rejtőzködő nem tudod hová néznek mit
terveznek ez pedig gyanakvás szül de mi
nem ragadozók vagyunk ha látom hogy rám
nézett tudom hogy jelen vagy ha tudom
hogy jelen vagy számíthatok rád és a
bizalom az ami mindent összetart bár
láthatatlan mégis hatalmas erőként
tartja össze a közösségünket egy-egy
nehézséget és tragédiát így tud
átvészelni egy nemzet egy cég egy
szervezet hogy bízik abban a közös
gondolatban ami eleve összetartja ezt a
közösséget ilyen szempontból fontos
elgondolkoznunk családapaként
családfőként vezetőként szülőként hogy
mi is az ami összetartja a közösségünket
mi az a közös történet közös idea ami
miatt azáltal hogy mindenki hisz benne
egymásba is megbízhatunk ezért fontos
hogy legyenek közös ünnepeink közös
múltunk amire emlékszünk és hogy
komolyan is vegyük hiszen az a nemzet
aki elfelejti ezeket az lassan elgyengül
és szétesik a bizalom mint a legjobb
befektetés sokan tapasztaltuk már hogy
az emberek nem mindig tartják be a
szavukat én azokat akik rendszeresen
elmulasztják 60%-os embereknek hívom
mert 10 ből nagyjából hat ígéretük
teljesedik be a többit pedig elfelejtik
vagy figyelmen kívül hagyják néha
konfliktuskererülésből máskor egyszerű
kényelemből szemet hújunk efölött és úgy
teszünk minthogyha nem történt volna
semmi de az igazság az hogy az emberek
tudat alatt pontosan számon tartják hogy
kiben lehet megbízni és kiben nem sőt az
lesz az igazán szokatlan és meglepő
számukra ha valaki következetesen
megbízható ha valaki ígér valamit és azt
mindig be is tartja ez eleén te úgy
tesznek az emberek minthogyha
természetes lenne nem fognak
különösebben reagálni rá hiszen így is
kellene működnie a dolgoknak de a
hónapok és az évek alatt az emberek
elkezdik másként látni ezt a személyt
minden szavának súlya lesz mert tudják
hogy ha kimondott valamit az meg is fog
történni ekkor válik a bizalom a
legerősebb valutává a bizalom olyan mint
a legjobb befektetés ami elérhető
számunkra ha a kompetencia és a
megbízhatóság egy emberben összpontosul
akkor a puszta jelenléte is értéket
teremt vannak emberek akiket egy-egy
fontos megbeszélésre nem azért hívnak el
hogy aktívan hozzászóljanak hanem csak
azért hogy jelen legyenek az ő figyelmük
már önmagában garancia arra hogy a
lehető legjobb döntés fog születni én
gyakr mondogatom a munkatársaimnak hogy
amit mondok azt vegyék 100%-osnak ez nem
azt jelenti hogy tökéletes vagyok hanem
azt jelenti hogy ha valamit nem tudok
betartani akkor felelősséget vállalok
érte és bocsánatot kérek sőt kifejez
bátorítom őket arra hogy számon kérjenek
ha valamit elmulasztok egy vezető egy
szülő egy munkatárs nem attól lesz
hiteles hogy soha nem hibázik hanem
attól hogy vállalja a felelősséget és
következetesen törekszik a
megbízhatóságra gandhi soha nem
rendelkezett semmilyen formális
hatalommal mégis annyira bíztak benne az
emberek hogy szinte egyetlen személyként
segítette elő india felszabadulását ez a
bizalom nem jött létre egyik napról a
másikra hanem következetes őszinte és
hiteles életvitel ered ménye volt a
bizalom bankszámlája olyan mint egy
lassan gyarapodó de annál értékesebb
vagyon nagyon nehéz növelni és nagyon
könnyű elveszíteni évek munkája lehet
építeni de egyetlen rossz döntéssel
komolyan megingathhatjuk egy házasságban
például egyetlen árulás vagy hűtlenség
évtizedek bizalmát törheti össze egy
pillanat alatt mindezek ellenére megéri
a bizalom építésé befektetni mert ha
egyszer kialakul akkor olyan biztos
alapokat ad amelyek hosszútávon minden
kapcsolatunkat erősebbé és stabilabbá
teszi ebben a videóban most egy konkrét
példát hozok a bizalom építésére
mégpedig az elvárások pontos tisztázását
a patreon változatban pedig folytatom
tovább más gyakorlati példákkal is hogy
hogyan építhetjük a bizalmat tudatosan a
kiemelkedően eredményes emberek
hétszokásában kavi egy nagyon szép
példát hozott erre kavi elmeséli ebben a
könyvben hogy hogyan kötött egyességet a
lányával hogy hogyan használhassa a
családi autót ez egy tökéletes példa
arra hogy a bizalom nem egy vakhit hanem
egy tudatosan felépített rendszer
amelyben mind a két fél pontosan tudja
mit várhat a másiktól amikor kavil lánya
elérte azt a kort hogy már vezethetett
természetesen felmerült a kérdés hogy
mikor és milyen feltételekkel
használhatja az autót egy tipikus szülői
reakció ilyenkor az lenne hogy rendben
használhatod de kérlek vigyázz rá ami
teljesen érvényes kérés de borzasztóan
homályos mert mit jelent az hogy vigyázz
rá kavi ehelyett leült a lányával és egy
egyértelmű mindenki szám mára világos
megállapodás kötött a lánya felelősséget
vállalt bizonyos dolgokért például
hetente egyszer kitakarítja és lemossa
az autót és mindig teletankolja ha
használja ha a szüleinek szükségük van
az autóra akkor szívesen elviszi őket
oda ahová kell cserébe kavi vállalta a
következőket ő fizeti a biztosítást és a
nagyobb karbantartási költségeket kavi
fizeti az üzemanyagot is ha ezeket a
lánya betartja akkor az autó használata
alapvetően szabad lesz számára nem csak
szóban állapodtak meg hanem le is is
írták ezt a megállapodást és mind a
ketten aláírták ez egy szimbolikus lépés
volt amely a lánya számára is
egyértelművé tette ez nem egy laza
szülői engedmény hanem egy valódi
felelősségeken alapuló egyesség és ami a
legfontosabb ezzel a tiszta egyértelmű
elvárásrendszerrel nemcsak az
autóhasználatról állapodtak meg hanem a
bizalom egy magasabb szintjét is
felépítették a lánya pontosan tudta hogy
mit várnak el tőle és azt is ha betartja
a megállap ást a szülei is megbíznak
benne bizalmat építeni sok más dologgal
lehet mint például az ígéretek
betartásával bocsánatkéréssel
pontossággal lojalitással ezek
gyakorlati példáiról lesz szó a patreon
videóban amelynek a linkjét megtalálod a
videó leírásában köszönöm hogy velem
tartottatok és kérlek iratkozzatok fel
adjatok egy lájkot és ha tetszett ez az
epizód hagyjatok egy kommentet ami
megerősít engem is abban hogy érdemes
ezt
[Zene]
folytatnom ه